[Music]
but then consciousness and life dies
that could be the future
i think this is the last chance to try
to snap out of that
we're the only species with the capacity
to see that our own
psychology our own emotions our own
paleolithic evolutionary system has been
hijacked
if not currently one day there will be a
simulation that's indiscernible from
regular reality and it seems we're on
that path
this is the thing that's warping our
view of reality it's an algorithm issue
right i'm pointing at a thing at your
brain to figure out what how can i show
you an infinite feed that just maximally
enrages you
and when you're sitting there and you
think okay i'm gonna go watch i'm gonna
look at this one thing on facebook
because my friend invited me to this
event or it's this one post i have to
look at and then next thing you know you
find yourself scrolling through the
thing for like an hour right and you say
man that was on me i should have had
more self-control but there behind the
screen behind that glass slab is like a
super computer pointed at your brain
that is predicting the perfect thing to
show you next it'll figure out the right
thing to show you that it knows will
keep you there what is their business
model it's it's engagement it's like how
do i get that attention at all costs
yeah so algorithms is one piece of that
meaning um when you're on a news feed
like i don't want to just show you any
news i want to show you the most viral
engaging like longest argumentative
comment threads news right so that's
like pointing a trillion dollar market
cap ai at your brain saying i'm going to
show you the next perfect boogeyman for
your nervous system the thing that's
going to make you upset angry it will
just drive that over and over again and
then repeat that thing and that's one of
the the tools in the arsenal to get
attention is that the algorithms another
one is technology making design
decisions like how do we inflate
people's sense of
beautification filters they're all
competing first of all to like inflate
your sense of beauty they're competing
for who can give you a nicer filter
right and then now instead of waiting
for you to actually add one tiktok was
actually found to actually do like a two
percent like just bare beautification
filter on the no filter mode because the
thing is once they do that the other
guys have to do it too
so i just want to name that all of this
is taking place in this race to capture
human attention because if i don't do it
the other guy will
and then it's happening with design
decisions like the beautification
filters and like the follow you and if
you follow me i'll follow you back and
the like button and check pulled refresh
the dopamine stuff that's all design
then there's the algorithms which is i'm
pointing at a thing at your brain to
figure out what how can i show you an
infinite feed that just maximally
enrages you and we should talk about
that because that thing drives
polarization which breaks democracy the
problem statement for humanity is he
said the fundamental problem of humanity
is we have paleolithic emotions and
brains like easy brains that are
hackable for magicians we have medieval
institutions you know government that's
not really good at seeing the latest
tech whether it was railroads or now
social media or ai or deep fakes or
whatever's coming next and then we have
god-like technology so we have
paleolithic emotions medieval
institutions
god-like technology
you combine that fact that's the
fundamental problem statement the speed
at which new technologies are having
effects on the world and the total
amount of consequence is way faster than
regulation can keep up with found ways
of keeping people engaged i think this
is important for people to get that
they're not competing for your data or
for
uh you know money they're competing to
keep people using the product and so
when twitter for example invented
this persuasive feature of the number of
followers that you have if you remember
like that was a new thing at the time
right you log in and you see your
profile
here's the people who you can follow and
then here's the number of followers you
have that created a reason for you to
come back every day to see how many
followers do i have so that was part of
this race to keep people engaged if
you're not paying for the product you
are the product but the thing that is
the product is your predictable behavior
so they also added this retweet this
instant resharing feature right and that
made it more addictive because suddenly
we're all playing the fame lottery right
like i could retweet your stuff and then
you get a bunch of hits and then you
could go viral and you could get a lot
of attention so then instead of um the
companies competing for attention now
each of us suddenly win the fame lottery
over and over and over again and we're
we're getting attention jaren lanier
says in the film if you just tilt
society by one degree two degrees that's
the whole world that's that's what
everyone is thinking and believing what
is the basis upon which we're believing
the things we are about the world and
increasingly that's that's based on
technology this is like humans have to
fight back
to reclaim our autonomy and free will
from the machines i mean
one clear okay neo
it's very much the matrix and one of my
favorite lines is actually when the
oracle says to neo and don't worry about
the vase and he says what face and he
knocks it over that face and so it's
like she's the ai who sees so many moves
ahead in the chessboard she can say
something which will cause him to do the
thing that verifies the thing that she
predicted would happen yeah
that's what ai is doing now except it's
pointed at our nervous system and
figuring out the perfect thing to dangle
in front of our dopamine system and get
the thing to happen
you